[Music]
it's gargantuan seven storied structure
with no apparent rhyme or reason built
on the orders of a grieving widow Sara
Winchester's mind is chaotic as the
house itself were worried about her
sanity dr. price
mrs. Winchester's a pleasure to finally
meet you you believe in ghosts dr. price
I do not believe in anything I cannot
see or study I feel the presence in the
air in the walls it has found her mrs.
Winchester father
well then construction on the spirit
killed by the rifle we lock them away
thirteen nails seals the moon I will do
whatever it takes to protect my family
[Applause]
[Music]
the spirit has a power we've not seen
before starlight and dewdrops awaiting
for the sounds of the
hello your anger will never defeat us
the long time ago
Devil's raided my village mother
now I have just a safe
let's water for the master
there is only one god of this city and
it is money me brother did he harm you
you were free once were you not I was
once I have chosen to spread the message
of equality there is talk of freedom are
there any spaces in my house great men
of those to choose their own destiny I
am as free a man as you are remember
being a great man means living without
the change
the ones in here come follow me
gather my chains ah
word of your defiance makes its way
through all the city
prepare yourself the bill health
they patent together two ovals rose
I believe we are all bored people's what
just inspire the hearts of men
unite us as one
no change withholding
[Music]
show me how your voice will inspire chip
morning wife
[Music]
this is gray look at your window no I'm
taking you away for the weekend I just
can't believe this is my life that I get
to live with you
buzzes hi
that meant nothing to me before you can
agree his office we wanted to welcome
the new fiction editor I bought it for
us I should have asked you first
oh my god Christian this is Jim Matteo
the architect this location is perfect
I'm going to build you a fabulous house
please stop speaking to my husband as if
I weren't here Anna you may call me mrs.
gray I'll pick you up at 5:00 I may not
be done by then
career follows
how the hell are you Anna
Jack what do you want
see one play yes sir right
I made a vow to love you faithfully
forsaking all others did you sleep with
her to comfort you when times of need
and to keep you safe first long as we
both shall live
Oh generous honest pure graceful
creatures our natural rapid pace to be
able to be sure what that would never
have worked no pants you must be Peter
Rabbit that's right wait did you try to
eat me show me your teeth do like a go
bug it was you how are you so good to
see
[Music]
this way
[Music]
new neighbor
I'll explain it to him we'll share our
land around here hello I'm B these gates
are incredibly sturdy I just need to
keep the wildlife out where they belong
there are angels this is their place
okay so he's trichter there's only one
way out of this he's gotta go his face
was so classic I have a vermin problem
an electric fence will keep a now
look away we can't give up it's our home
you're mine rabbit
[Applause]
[Music]
let's go wait - boys guess you're alone
nothing could make me happier I got us
into this I'm gonna fix it
[Music]
smacks coming into a clock gentlemen
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
once you begin to discover who you are
then you really realize how you have
been given authority over your life
but you can only do that through the
struggle of life and
the stuff
go write the boarding
[Music]
[Applause]
on a dream at some point in time a
transition takes place
[Music]
you start challenging this
[Music]
something in
nor the giver
take you the shortcuts do
[Music]
I don't know man you ever just feel like
life is just pushing us towards
something like some greater purpose
[Music]
[Music]
I have seen gods fly I've seen men build
weapons that I couldn't even imagine
I've seen aliens drop from the sky yeah
but I have never seen anything like this
how much more uit
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
my son it is your time
you get to decide what kind of King you
are going to be
don't freeze
[Music]
because we own
because we don't know
cuz we young young I waited my entire
life for this the world's gonna start
over I'm a burn at all what happens now
determines what happens to the rest of
the world
[ __ ]
[Music]
tonight we're taking game night up a
notch Oh morning someone in this room is
going to be taken and it's gonna be up
to you to find them it's a murder
mystery party whoever finds the victim
wins the grand prize you're not gonna
know what's real and what's fake wait a
second can't just come in here and break
the door the home guys make sure you get
a piece of this cheese it's just okay
Roger dad you drive safe
I've always enjoyed the camaraderie of
good friends competing in games of
chance and skill to revalue it seems
like him Ryan you go first I'm scared
[Music]
it's not a joke people are in real
danger
[Music]
oh so much worse
stop wait me I have kids at home not
with an ass like yet you don't oh thank
you oh no he died his instructions on
how to remove a bullet she didn't have
rubbing alcohol so I got you this lovely
sharp good idea way to pivot and then a
squeaky toy for the pain I am someone
who wakes up in a different body every
day
always someone my age I never too far
from that last never the same person
twice and I have absolutely no control
over any of it the day that Amy shadow
duets or I was Amy in the day that you
went to the beach with Justin I was
Justin it's not possible it is hey it's
me every day of your life you've just
woken up and just try to live that day
for that person
that sounds really lonely it isn't
because I know what makes each person
different and what makes everyone the
same why are you doing this
dailymed I felt something I've never
felt before I don't want to let that go
I am so proud thank you
I'm in love with someone who wakes up in
a different body every day always the
same age never the same person twice for
such a bright beautiful kind funny
person
tomorrow wake up as the kid who's not
flying back here oh my god this kid is
not exercise
[Music]
I have to go wait whoever was that
I'm forcing Alexander out of his own
life in that's wrong what are you saying
think about what happens if you and I
stay together we can make it work I want
to believe that
[Music]
what will happen to your life if I'm the
person in the world that you're closest
to
you know I thought you'd left left I'd
never leave there than every day
[Music]